erfolge für linke und afd in thüringen
doch wer das land künftig regieren wird
ist völlig offen
ps-chef al bagdadi ist tot der
meistgesuchte terrorist sprengt sich
offenbar während einer us militäraktion
in die luft und misslungener ski auftakt
in sölden nach den deutschen damen
platzen auch die herren beim ersten
riesenslalom der saison
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an diesem wahlsonntag kristin
otto ist auch dabei für den sport wer
gerne guten abend ein paukenschlag in
thüringen die linke von
ministerpräsident bodo ramelow ist
erstmals stärkste partei in einem
bundesland
allerdings sind ihre beiden
koalitionspartner spd und grüne so
schwach dass es für eine
regierungsmehrheit wie bisher nicht
reichen wird
die afg mit bieren herke kann ihr
ergebnis mehr als verdoppeln
die cdu dagegen jahrzehntelang stärkste
partei in thüringen muss kräftig federn
lassen und wir gehen direkt in unser
wahlstudio nach er vor zu matthias
fornoff matthias wie sehen die neuesten
zahlen aus
guten abend hier sind die neuesten
zahlen die dritte hochrechnung 19 uhr
demnach kommt die cdu auf 22 prozent der
stimmen die linke auf 29,4 die spd auf 8
prozent die afd 23,9 die grüne 5,3 und
die fdp 5,5 prozent diese beiden
letzteren also noch nicht so sicher
drüber über der fünf prozent hürde weil
so viel bewegung drin ist im vergleich
zu vor fünf jahren schauen wir uns das
ganze mal in gewinnen und verlusten an
da sehen wir kräftige verluste minus
11,3 punkte bei der cdu linke plus 1,3
spd minus 4,4 afd die meisten zugewinne
plus 13,2 punkte
die grünen verlieren leicht die fdp
gewinnt 3 prozentpunkte dazu
jetzt schauen wir uns mal anders heißt
das für die sitzverteilung hier im
erfurter landtag 45 sitze bedeuten die
absolute mehrheit die cdu kommt auf 21
die linke auf 28 die spd auf 7
die afg auf 22 sitze grüne 5 und fdp
ebenfalls fünf wer kann in dieser
konstellation mit wem regieren wir sehen
hier rechts die senkrechte linie 45
sitze
das braucht man mindestens zum regieren
die koalition die wir derzeit hier in
erfurt haben linke spd und grüne
verfehlt das deutlich mit 40 sitzen erst
recht geht cdu spd grüne nicht auch dann
nicht wenn die fdp mit dazu kommt linke
spd grüne und fdp sicher eine
ungewöhnliche konstellation die würde
derzeit genau auf diese
45 sitze kommen und auch wenn von der
cdu ausgeschlossen zeigen wer das jetzt
hier mal linke und cdu 49 sitze wäre
deutlich drüber die wahlbeteiligung
übrigens ist deutlich gestiegen auf
jetzt 66 prozent trotz der schwierigen
regierungsbildung die da zu erwarten ist
für die linke ist es ja ein klasse
ergebnis welche rolle spielte dabei die
popularität von bodo ramelow
ja es hat sicher einen amtsbonus für
bodo ramelow gegeben eine deutliche
mehrheit der thüringer wenn ihnen weiter
als ministerpräsidenten sehen vom
schreckgespenst eines linken
regierungschefs ist nicht viel geblieben
im gegenteil drei viertel der thüringer
bescheinigen ihm seine arbeit gut zu
machen und das trägt sicher auch dazu
bei dass es hier keine erkennbare
wechselstimmung gegeben hat dankeschön
matthias fornoff für den moment wer wird
künftig mit wem in thüringen regieren
die wähler stellen die politiker mit
diesem ergebnis vor eine echte
herausforderung
bettina schausten hat in erfurt die
spitzenkandidaten um sich versammelt was
machen wir jetzt aus diesem ergebnis
bettina das ist die frage das ist ein
wahlergebnis das wirklich viele fragen
auf wird die wir in fünf die wir in
dieser runde sicherlich nicht
erschöpfend beantworten können aber die
zentralen fragen wollen wir natürlich
auch für unsere zuschauer
wir stellen und die erste geht an den
wahlsieger des heutigen abends bodo
ramelow der linke ministerpräsident was
machen sie nun aus dieser komplizierten
situation herr ramelow streben sie eine
förmliche minderheitsregierung an
oder bieten sie der cdu gespräche an
erstmals so dass spielen abend abwarten
sollten wir müssen abwarten bis das
amtliche endergebnis vorliegt und dann
werden wir sehen wie es genau mit den
sitzverteilung im parlament ist aber
erstmal finde ich es großartig dass die
wahlbeteiligung seit jahren noch nicht
so hoch war wie sie heute war die
demokratie in thüringen hat gewonnen und
sie hat uns jetzt eine komplizierte
aufgabe gestellt aber demokraten sollten
miteinander in der lage sein für eine
ausreichende kraft im parlament zu
sorgen mike mohring ist hier das sind
herbe verluste für die cdu in einem land
in thüringen wo die cdu die
ministerpräsidenten sehr häufig gestellt
hat sie haben
versucht die macht zurückerobern das ist
ihnen nicht gelungen
könnten sie sich vorstellen jetzt signal
auch in richtung linke zu setzen
wir haben für die mehrheit für eine
demokratische mitte geworben diese mitte
hat keine mehrheit bekommen
das stimmt mich sehr nachdenklich an
diesem abend weil auch niemand damit
gerechnet hat dass linke und fdp so
stark sind dass in der mitte die
mehrheitlich möglich ist wir haben ein
viertel der stimmen bekommen da haben
dann beauftragt dafür den müssen
sachgerecht und den blick auf thüringens
zukunft umsetzen der wähler gerne
festhalten
rot rot grün hat keine mehrheit mehr die
regierung ist abgewählt worden es gibt
keine linke mehrheit in diesem land und
ich stelle auch fest die stärke von
ramelow auch zu lasten von grünen spd
gegangen ist dass auch die erkenntnis
des heutigen abends aber thüringen
braucht eine stabile regierung darauf
wird es ankommen wenn thüringen sein
wort in deutschland machen will und dazu
müssen wir jetzt in ruhe nachdenken was
es bedeutet aber es wäre zu früh und
zuviel das heute abend zu besprechen
weil damit konnte niemand rechnen dass
sie demokratische mitte heute keine
mehrheit gefunden
weiter zur bisherigen regierungspartei
spd die erneut stark verloren hat das es
sind fast ein drittel stimmen weniger
hier in thüringen wolfgang tiefensee ist
der spitzenkandidat und
wirtschaftsminister hier ja was machen
sie jetzt aus diesem ergebnis bleiben
sie an der seite von bodo ramelow in
einer rot rot grünen
minderheitsregierung unmöglich das
ergebnis enttäuschend
das ergebnis der linken hervorragend
gratulation gratulation an die
wählerschaft die für ein offenes und
tolerantes thüringen gewählt hat weniger
als 80 prozent
die hecke partei gewählt hat ja es ist
für uns kompliziert weil es eine
polarisierung der parteien oberhalb von
20 prozent gegeben hat das geht zulasten
derer die unter zehn prozent sind
wenn herr morrigan von der
demokratischen mitte spricht dann muss
man ihnen widersprechen wir sind
demokratische parteien die vom linken
spektrum bis in die mitte reichen wir
haben gute politik gemacht die spd würde
mit einer etwas weniger hohen
prozentzahl dennoch stark weiter politik
machen
wir schauen nach vorn wir schauen uns
das ergebnis an werden
die möglichkeit schaffen weiter eine
gute regierung für thüringen zu stellen
dieses hervorragende land geht voran
auch mit der spd helga sie konnten ihr
ergebnis fast verdoppeln mehr als
verdoppeln das ist für sie ein erfolg
was machen sie da raus also erstmal bin
ich dankbar dafür dass fast ein viertel
der thüringer sich nicht haben von hass
und hetze beeindrucken lassen
neben tatsächlich ein stück
parteigeschichte hier geschrieben und
parlamentsgeschichte das ist die größte
steigerung die jemals im freistaat
thüringen für eine partei erzielt worden
ist darauf bin ich sehr stolz und dafür
möchte ich mich sehr herzlich bedanken
die umweltministerin hier von den grünen
ist bei uns und sie haben nichts von
ihren zehn erreicht die hießen nämlich
womöglich zweistellig werden
was machen sie jetzt aus diesem
regierung aus diesem ergebnis sind sie
in einer regierung dabei sind sie dazu
geradezu verdammt oder sagen sie wir
orientieren uns jetzt erstmal für uns
neu als nächste mal haben wir einen sehr
engagierten wahlkampf gemacht und alles
daran gesetzt natürlich zu überzeugen
wir haben einen sehr polarisierten
wahlkampf wahr genommen wir haben als
grüne gesagt wir setzen demut entgegen
und so sehr ich mich freue dass die
wahlbeteiligung gestiegen es ist
schmerzt mich dass die fdp so viele
stimmen bekommen hat wir als grüne haben
gemeinsam mit linken und spd in dieser
regierung viele dinge bewegen können wir
stehen natürlich jetzt auch für
gespräche bereit verantwortung das
zeichnet uns aus eben für unsere stamm
themen die eine starke demokratie und
mehr klimaschutz sind herr kemmerich sie
haben bis zum schluss nicht daran
geglaubt dass sie die fünf-prozent-hürde
schaffen aber sie haben es geschafft sie
haben gewählt
sie haben damit geworben dass sie das
zünglein an der waage sein werden was
bieten sie jetzt an
ich habe immer daran geglaubt und ich
bin stolz auf die demokratie in auf die
wähler der fdp weil sie haben den mut
bewiesen trotz mancher voraussagen ihre
stimme bei uns abzugeben
wir haben auch immer erklärt wir sind
bereit regierungsverantwortung zu
übernehmen und wir haben klare angebote
den politikfeldern bildung wirtschaft
infrastrukturanbindung des landes aber
auch sicherheitsgefühl für thüringen zu
verbessern und die nächsten tage werden
zeigen ersten wir müssen den abend
abwarten die nächsten tage werden zeigen
wo man in den politikfeldern nach wie
vor aus der mitte der gesellschaft
mehrheiten abbilden kann ich denke auch
minderheitsregierung oder andere
konstellationen werden interessante
diskussionspunkte sein die wir dann mit
den parteien mit den vertretern der
parteien die sich an der demokratie
stellen abhalten können und wir sehen
thüringen stehen komplizierte gespräche
ins haus und mit dieser runde zurück
nach mainz zu barbara hahlweg in den
dank an alle beteiligten die linke und
die af den können also feiern für die
regierungsparteien in berlin für spd und
union muss das ergebnis dieser
landtagswahl im osten dagegen
frustrierend sein hier die reaktionen
aus der hauptstadt
das ist ein sensationelles ergebnis bei
dieser gestiegenen wahlbeteiligung noch
einmal zuzulegen das erste mal in einem
bundesland stärkste partei zu sein
das ist das verdienst von bodo ramelow
natürlich auch das verdienst der
thüringer linken ich sage es ein
historischer ein sensationeller sieg bei
dieser wahl hat sich eben wieder einmal
mehr gezeigt ähnlich wie in brandenburg
und in sachsen dass es gerade in den
letzten tagen und wochen zu einer
starken polarisierung gekommen ist
zwischen dem regierungs dem
ministerpräsidenten in dem fall und der
afd
grundsätzlich ist es so dass die
ostdeutschen landesverbände gestärkt
natürlich in ihrem einfluss aus diesen
wahlen hervorgehen weil wir drei mal
sehr große erfolge hatten
und das ist eine geschichte die wir als
gesamtpartei mit großer befriedigung
erleben dass wir so stark im osten sind
wir müssen diese erfolge jetzt auch im
westen umsetzen die demokratische mitte
hat keine regierungsoption aber ich sage
ihnen ganz deutlich auch heute abend wir
bleiben bei dem was wir auf dem
bundesparteitag beschlossen haben was
mike mohring auch selbst immer wieder
gesagt hat es wird mit der union keine
koalition mit den linken und auch nicht
mit der fdp geben
natürlich total dramatische situationen
eigentlich
und sie zeigt dass wir in einer phase wo
sich die demokratie neu sortiert aus
diese ried ist eigentlich nicht brauchen
können also eigentlich kann man nur
sagen dass alle demokratischen parteien
miteinander gesprächsfähig sein müssen
mal sehen wie der wahlabend endet aber
das ist die lehre denke ich auf diesem
wahlabend
das könnte uns etwas gelingen was uns
nicht gelungen ist vor der letzten
bundestagswahl nämlich in ostdeutschland
im parlament ein
es könnte uns etwas gelingen was uns
seit zehn jahren nicht mehr gelungen ist
nämlich erfolgreich zu sein bei einer
ostdeutschen landtagswahl
weitere zahlen und reaktionen gibt es
gleich im anschluss an diese nachrichten
in der zdf wahlsendungen und direkt
dabei sind sie auch auf heute.de wo wir
sie in unserem live blog auf dem
laufenden halten
es gab auch noch andere nachrichten
heute der chef der terror miliz wie es
abu bakr al baghdadi ist tot er sei als
feigling gestorben erklärte us präsident
ab heute stolz der öffentlichkeit
al bagdadi sprengte sich demnach in die
luft als das us-militär sein versteck in
syrien angriff der iraker stand seit
fünf jahren an der spitze des
selbsternannten islamischen staats er
war einer der meistgesuchten terroristen
der welt mehrfach dachte man er sei tot
bis diese bilder im april auftauchten
mit einer kriegserklärung an die welt
ines trams berichtet ungewöhnlich am
sonntag die morgendlichen talkshows
ändern ihr programm präsident trump hat
ein statement angekündigt er bestätigt
was seit dem abend als gerücht die runde
gemacht hatte vergangene nacht haben die
usa den schlimmsten terroristen führer
der welt so bestraft wie er es verdient
al bagdadi ist tot
us-spezialkräfte hatten sich dem
versteckt da dies im nordwesten syriens
genährt in einem tunnel hätte der sich
dann mit einer sprengstoffweste in die
luft gesprengt die endproben belegten er
ist es trumps selber verfolgte den
schlag gegen al bagdadi im weißen haus
am morgen lob für die operation
al bagdadi war böse und gewalttätig er
starb nun auf gewalttätige weise wie ein
feigling auf der flucht und weinend
dieser überraschungsangriff lief
tadellos al baghdadi zuerst hatte er al
qaida im irak übernommen dann den so
genannten ines begründet
eine schreckensherrschaft über weite
teile iraks und syriens die mit
gräueltaten und blutigen anschlägen die
weltgemeinschaft gegen sich aufbrachte
der schlag in der nacht auch das
endgültige ende des hat eine ideologie
zu zerschlagen
wir müssen also in hab-acht-stellung
bleiben um solche ziele zu zerstören
wenn sie wieder aufkommen trump feiert
sich für diesen schlag betonte
allerdings es bleibt beim abzug der usa
aus syrien dafür hat er viel kritik
einstecken müssen
wir fragen noch mal nach bei m at wissen
in washington der us verliert sein
führer was bedeutet das jetzt für diese
terrors
also es ist ohne zweifel ein ganz
wichtiger militärischer und auch
politischer erfolg für die trump in
administration aber abu bakr al baghdadi
hat in den letzten 12 jahren eigentlich
keine entscheidende rolle für den ie es
mehr gespielt der us und seine ideologie
haben sich in dieser zeit weiter
ausgebreitet rund um den erdball von
ländern wie philippinen über afghanistan
bis eben auch nach nord und ostafrika
und dazu hat beigetragen eine
amerikanische außenpolitik die er auf
rückzug setzt gerade in den letzten
wochen haben wir das ja gesehen dass
durch diesen rückzug beispielsweise in
syrien mehrere hundert kämpfer und ihre
unterstützer entkommen sind aus den
gefängnissen und die lage in syrien und
irak im nachbarstaat hat sich weiter so
die stabilisiert dass das fruchtbarer
boden für diese islamistische ideologie
ist also das ganze ist ein wichtiger
militärischer erfolg aber den sieg über
den as zu programmieren wie das der
us-präsident getan hat anders als sein
eigener verteidigungsminister das glaube
ich ist eine gefährliche
fehleinschätzung
vielen dank für diese informationen aus
washington mrt wissen gestern noch war
außenminister maß in der türkei heute
ist er nach libyen weiter gereist in
einem vom bürgerkrieg zerrissenen land
seit dem sturz von machthaber gaddafi
2011 kämpfen dort milizen um einfluss
und macht und um die kostbaren ölfelder
libyens chaos ein nährboden für
kriminelle geschäfte schlepperbanden
bereichern sich an flüchtlingen die nach
europa wollen
und überlassen sie versklavung und
folter ein chaos das auch der
außenminister bei seinem besuch in sarah
erlebt hat wie andreas köhlers berichtet
die verzweiflung ist übergroß und sie
ist überall
der deutsche außenminister in einem
libyschen flüchtlingscamp wo sie seit
monaten manche seit jahren dahin
vegetieren es ist kein leben
als heiko maas den journalisten
berichten will muss abbringen
entschieden ihn seine partie ganz zurück
in den gepanzerten jeep ein verdächtiges
flugzeug sei in der luft willkommen in
libyen
das trifft den machtlosen machthaber sei
rasch der seine ganze vielleicht letzte
hoffnung auf deutschland setzt das im
auftrag der uno vermittelt wir wollen
die voraussetzungen schaffen dass die
konfliktparteien im nächsten schritt
ohne einmischung von außen verhandeln
können
bisher verhindert die einmischung von
außen verhindern waffen und geld
lieferungen dass libyen miteinander
verhandelt die regierung verrat herrscht
über nicht viel mehr als über tripolis
und umgebung im größten teil libyens hat
der schillernde bord und selbsternannte
feldmarschall haft das sagen bis an die
hauptstadt sind die kämpfe herangerückt
es gibt keine regeln kein reden es gibt
keinen staat alle vermittler sind bisher
gescheitert nun hat die uno die
bundesregierung gebeten
deutschland versucht erst gar nicht die
verfeindeten anführer an einen tisch zu
zwingen sondern stattdessen deren
ausländische unterstützer seit wochen
laufen diskreter verhandlungen mal im
kanzleramt mal im auswärtigen amt
das ziel eine libyen konferenz in berlin
schon morgen will maas nach ägypten
reisen dass die gegner der libyschen
regierung unterstützt die erwartungen
sind hoch die chancen niedrig heftige
kritik vom koalitionspartner erntete maß
für seine äußerungen gestern in ankara
er hatte sich dort ablehnend über den
syrien vorschlag von
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer geäußert cdu-außenpolitiker
norbert röttgen spricht von einem
peinlichen moment der deutschen
außenpolitik wirtschaftsminister
altmaier twitterte es sei klar dass man
vom ausland aus weder die opposition
noch die eigene regierung kritisiert als
konsequenz aus dem anschlag von halle
will die bundesregierung das waffen und
sprengstoffrecht verschärfen bevor ein
waffenschein erteilt wird müssen künftig
die verfassungsschutzbehörden gefragt
werden erklärte justizministerin
lamprecht diese regelanfrage ist teil
eines neuen punkte paktes gegen
rechtsextremismus und hasskriminalität
es soll am mittwoch vom kabinett
verabschiedet werden
zu einem hoch umstrittenen thema der
katholischen kirche dürfen verheiratete
männer zu priestern geweiht werden
das war eine der zentralen fragen einer
bischofssynode im vatikan allerdings
ging es nur um das amazonasgebiet weil
dort akuter priestermangel herrscht die
bischöfe hatten sich in ihrer
abschlusserklärung für eine
ausnahmeregelung für den amazonas
ausgesprochen die synode ging heute mit
einer messe mit papst franziskus zu ende
was aus dem vorstoß wird entscheidet der
papst
nach mannheim dort hat der
bundespräsident den mit 500.000 euro
dotierten deutschen umweltpreis
verliehen
dabei lobte er die engagierte jugend
mahnte aber auch sorgen der menschen um
ihre arbeitsplätze ernst zu nehmen
ausgezeichnet wurde die boden forscherin
ingrid kohler knabe aus münchen und der
unternehmer reinhard schneider aus mainz
er zeigt wie umweltschutz und putzmittel
zusammenpassen eva schiller
diese kleinen kügelchen machen den
unterschied rezyklat also recyceltes
plastik daraus hat unternehmer schneider
schon über 300 millionen flaschen seiner
putzmittel marke frosch hergestellt ein
paar cent teurer ist das pro flasche
deswegen folgen seinem beispiel nur
wenige in der branche
das müsste nicht so sein wenn die
nachfrage nach diesem rohstoff wachsen
würde
und wir versuchen das anzuregen und
vorzumachen wie es geht
schneider ist vorangegangen als das
thema noch nicht so populär war
deshalb wurde er heute mit dem deutschen
umweltpreis geehrt der bundespräsident
lobte bei der gelegenheit die
klimaaktivisten waren aber auch vor
gesellschaftlicher spaltung wie bei
jedem tiefgreifenden strukturwandel gibt
es menschen die von diesem wandel
besonders stark betroffen sind menschen
die sorge haben ihre eigenen
arbeitsplätze zu verlieren und wir
dürfen diese sorgen auch nicht einfach
überheblich ignorieren trotzdem findet
familienunternehmer schneider beim thema
plastik müsste die regierung mehr druck
ausüben so konnte plastik überraschender
weise zu einer ökologischen stoffe
unserer zeit werden weil es mit sehr
wenig aufwand immer und immer wieder in
kreislauf gehalten werden könnte dass
hier ein wesentlicher beitrag zum
klimaschutz
und wenn die politik bereit wäre das zu
fördern wäre viel gewonnen
bei der produktion verzichtet schneider
auch weitgehend auf das ökologisch
umstrittene palmöl und energie für den
eigenbedarf erzeugt das unternehmen auf
dem firmendach
wegen der verheerenden waldbrände in
kalifornien müssen immer mehr menschen
ihre häuser verlassen
mittlerweile gelten die
evakuierungsanordnung fast für den
gesamten bezirk sonoma ein bekanntes
weinanbaugebiet 90.000 bewohner sind
schon vor den flammen geflüchtet
die behörden warnen dass sich die brände
wegen starker winde noch weiter
ausbreiten und damit sind wir beim sport
dieses sonntags wir gucken zuerst nach
asien nach japan zur rugby
weltmeisterschaft da steht das finale
fest england trifft kommenden samstag
auf südafrika
die neuauflage des endspiels von 2007
nach den all blacks aus neuseeland hatte
im zweiten halbfinale wales das
nachsehen
in einem taktisch geprägten match gibt
es lange zeit für beide teams nur
jeweils drei punkte nach straftritten
bis dann südafrika durch serien die
allende der erste sogenannte versuch
gelingt derzeit fünf punkte und nach dem
anschließenden kick von dia länder wie
südafrika zum ersten mal mit 16 zu 9
deutlich in führung doch die walliser
wehren sich mit erfolg und gleich nach
diesem straftritt von harf penny zum 16
16 aus
die entscheidung dann kurz vor schluss
als henry polat der allein 14 punkte
erzielt südafrika mit einem drei-punkte-
kick ins finale schießt wo allerdings am
nächsten samstag mit england der klare
favorit auf die springboks wartet im
ersten sonntagsspiel hat der vfl
wolfsburg durch das 0 0 gegen augsburg
die chance verpasst die tabellenführung
in der fußball-bundesliga zu übernehmen
und fehlstart für die deutschen alpinen
skifahrer stefan luitz wurde zum weltcup
auftakt in sölden im riesenslalom
sechzehnter ein super einstieg
erwischten dagegen zwei franzosen alexis
pinturault nimmt die glückwünsche seines
landsmanns mathieu faivre gerne
gegen die erste alpine saison nach dem
rücktritt des dominators marcel hirscher
beginnt mit einem französischen
doppelerfolg keiner schafft es wie fern
büro an den schlüsselstellen so nahe an
der ideallinie zu bleiben der franzose
unterstreicht dabei eindrucksvoll seine
ambitionen auf die nachfolge von
hirscher als gesamtweltcup sieger am
ende gewinnt er mit mehr als einer
halben sekunde vorsprung vor fairere und
dem slowenen zahn kann jetzt stefan lurz
ist dagegen noch ein gutes stück von der
topform entfernt blatt 16 ist für den
nach dem rücktritt von felix neureuther
besten deutschen techniker sicher nicht
das wunschergebnis ihr wisst nicht neue
chance in vier wochen im finnischen levi
ich danke und wir werden noch aufs
wetter morgen regnet es im schwarzwald
und südlich der donau sonst wechseln
sonne und wolken in küstennähe gibt es
einige schauer
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 8
und 13 grad die kommenden tage werden
überwiegend freundlich mit vier bis elf
grad jedoch recht kühl
das war es von uns wir sagen tschüss bis
morgen und wünschen ihnen noch einen
spannenden sonntagabend eine intensive
wahlnachlese bietet claus kleber nachher
um 15 im heute-journal und jetzt
natürlich live aus erfurt bettina
chancen